بالفعل
كما تشاهدون الان هي صور حصريه ومباشره
امامكم لوصول الطائره العسكريه الكوريه
الخاصه بعمليات الاجلاء الخاصه بالرعايه
الكوريين الدبلوماسيين وبمقدمتهم السفير
الكوري في الخرطوم كما نشاهد هذه الطائره
العسكريه على رقم سيء 130 وهي على متنها
29 موظف دبلوماسي في السفاره الكوريه في
الخرطوم بمقدمتهم كذلك
الكوري في الخرطوم ايضا نتحدث انه تمت
عمليات الاسلام من مطار برج سودان وايضا
على هذا الرقم كيف نتحدث على 77 شخص من
الرعايه الكوريين جميعهم من الرعايه
الكوريين وصلت هذه الطائره الان الى مطار
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده سوف يتم
استقبالهم من قبل السفير الكوري في
السعوديه وعدد من قيادات الامنيه هنا في
السعوديه كما نشاهد الان هذه الطائره وصلت
سوف يتم استقبالهم وانهاء كافه الاجراءات
السفر الخاصه بهم ومن ثم استق الطائره
الاخرى وصولا فورا خلال ساعه من بعد الان
الى العاصمه الكوريه سي او نتحدث انه هذه
الرحله تمت بعد تنسيق امني كبير ما بين
الحكومه السعوديه والحكومه الكوريه اذا
اذا بدات الرحله من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وصولا الى بورسودان برا ومن ثم جو
الهادي تعتبر اول رحله اخلاء جوي تصل الى
السعوديه وتحديدا الى القاعده الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه بالقطاع الغربي هذه
الصوره حيه كما نشاهد امامكم السفير
السعودي السفير الكوري بالسعوديه وعدد من
قطاع قطاع او قيادات الامنيه متواجدين
لاستقبالهم نتحدث انه هذه الرعايه سوف
يصلون سوف الان تنزلون من هذه الطائر
العسكريه التي تسمى 130 الان بانتظرون
هناك
موطفي من وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وعدد من
القطعات الامنيه كما نشاهد الان لاستقبال
اول عمليه اخلاء
جوي تتم من عبر مطار برج سودان وصولا الى
مدينه جده هنا في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه سلطان قبل قليل بعمليه النزول كما
نشاهد الان وذكرت قبل قليل انه بقائهم في
جده سيكون لمده ساعه فقط
لتخليص الاجراءات الورقيه ومن ثم مباشره
وكنا قد شاهدنا قبل قليل صور الطائره التي
ستنقلهم الى بلدهم الام
[موسيقى]
قليل هي جاهزه لعمليه نقلهم بعد انهاء
كافه اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم المتوقع ان
سوف يستغرق ذلك ساعه النظره لوجود
المديريه العامه للجوازات وكافه القطاعات
الامنيه للتسهيل عمليه وصولهم وسفرهم الى
سيول في كوريا نتحدث انه هنالك عدد كبير
من القطاعات الامنيه متواجده والحكوميه
لانهاء اجراءات سفرهم بعد الاطمئنان عليهم
والتاكيد من سلامتهم وصحتهم نتحدث لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات